[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW PEGULA: Hi, everybody.
MARY CHEN: Hi.
Happy Thursday.
MATTHEW PEGULA: We made
it to day three here.
OSCAR PROM: How about that
concert last night, huh?
MATTHEW PEGULA: Who knew
that's what fruit sounded like?
OSCAR PROM: Those
bananas can slap.
MARY CHEN: Attack of the fruits.
Well, we're super excited
you're here with us today.
Thank you so much for coming.
And hi to everyone
watching on livestream.
My name is Mary, and I'm part
of the Google Assistant team
that put together this
year's I/O. Hope you're
having a lot of fun, meeting
a lot of cool people,
and leave inspired to build
new actions for the Google
Assistant.
OSCAR PROM: And
my name is Oscar.
I'm the software team
lead at Deeplocal
and a four-year
Google I/O attendee.
I'm really excited to share all
of these demos with you today.
MATTHEW PEGULA:
My name's Matthew.
I lead up the Creative
Technology team at Deeplocal.
And as a little
background, Deeplocal
is an innovation studio
based in Pittsburgh.
And we've been lucky enough to
work with the Assistant team
for a while now
showcasing new Assistant
features in fun, creative ways.
So to that end, a
couple of quick examples
of what that looks like.
On the left here is
the Mocktails Mixer
you may have seen.
It's been at I/O before.
It's gone to the
Cannes Festival.
It's been pretty popular at
some our holiday parties back
at the office as well.
In the center here is a
collaborative drawing robot
we had at I/O last year where
you use voice to tell it,
hey, use the red
color now, or I want
you to draw circles or squares.
So you work together
with this machine
using your voice to create this
cool take-home piece of art.
And then finally, on the
right, this year at CES,
we created an interactive
ride to show how Assistant
fits into your daily life.
And it was this
over-the-top theme park
ride with animatronics and a
theme song and smoke and sound
effects.
So it was really cool
to bring Assistant
into the world in that
really extreme way.
MARY CHEN: And that
was an epic ride.
MATTHEW PEGULA:
Yeah, definitely.
MARY CHEN: Cool.
So I also want to say it's
a lot of fun collaborating
with the Deeplocal team, and
this year is no different.
Here we have a picture
of our Assistant Sandbox.
Thanks, Johnny, for
the great picture.
This year-- oh, for those
of you watching at home,
the sandbox is a physical place
attendees can come and learn
more about our
new features, chat
with the teams who made them,
and try out interactive demos.
This year, our team
wanted to make sure
that you get to see
the end results of what
you can build using these
cool features and tools.
We want to make sure you
leave inspired to build
the same things or even better.
OSCAR PROM: So this is what the
inside of the Assistant Sandbox
looks like.
As you'll see,
there are a handful
of awesome interactive demos
that we'll talk through
during this session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARY CHEN: Cool, a VIP tour.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So let's dive right in.
The very first demo, we
have interactive guides
on how to fold really
pretty or origami flowers.
These are made with our new
how-to templates and schema.org
markup.
Now, if you're a webmaster
or content creator,
Schema.org is very
familiar to you,
basically highlighting rich
content on your website
to display on search results.
Now, templates is
actually even easier.
All you have to do is fill out
some information on a Google
Sheet, and your content will
be available on Google Search.
There's no coding needed.
It's really that easy.
We already have
templates for quizzes,
making flashcards,
games, you name it.
But I'm particularly
excited about these
how to templates because
there's a lot of great
how to content out there.
I watch a lot of
instructional videos
on YouTube, recipes
on websites and such.
So I'm super excited
to see all this content
accessible by voice on
the Google Assistant.
Matthew, can you tell
us about these demos?
MATTHEW PEGULA: Absolutely.
So we created this
origami how-to guide
to utilize the new
how-to template.
You see in this
little video what
that ended up looking like.
Really, what we
wanted to do is show
how easy it is to
take YouTube content
and make it perfect for
use with smart displays.
So we chose origami
because it really
shows how powerful
Assistant can be
when you're trying
to do something
when you have your hands full.
So to make this demo, we
had to do three things,
and none of them
involved writing
even a single line of code.
First we created
our YouTube video.
In our case, we created
one from scratch
with this origami content, but
you could reuse existing videos
that you already have.
And it's a great way to get
even more functionality out
of content that you've
already worked to create.
The next thing we did was
go to the Actions console
and told it we wanted to create
a new template-based how-to.
To do that, all we have
to do is give it a name
and tell Google how we
want to invoke that action.
And then what's really
cool is after that,
a Google Sheet is
automatically created for you
that we can then use as a
template to fill in all our
how to information.
So that's the third step here.
We take that template.
We give it some information like
the URL to our YouTube video.
And then for each
step in our how to,
all we have to do is add
a new row to the sheet.
And we say, step one is
at the 10-second mark,
and it is fold
the paper in half.
Step two is at the
23-second mark,
and it's turn it 90 degrees
and fold it diagonally.
So for each step in
our how-to, we just
add a new row to that sheet.
And then when we're
done, here's how
it looks on our smart display.
You can see we get the video
of the current step we're on,
an outline on the left of
where we are in the process.
We can invoke this just like
we can any other action.
And then you can say things
like, hey, go to the next step,
or repeat that step,
so really great
bringing that how
to content in a way
that you can use it while
you're actually doing it.
What's also nice is you can
use Action Simulator, like you
can with other
actions, to really test
and tune this content.
So really easy to get this
YouTube video into this format.
So that was the how-to
templates for videos.
And along with that,
we wanted to show you
how you can use schema.org
how-to types for web content.
So this video gives a quick
overview about what we did.
You can check this out in the
sandbox and some of the code
examples at the end.
But basically, we're
adding metadata
to web pages that
explicitly calls out that it
contains how-to content.
So for this demo, we
had to do two things.
We had to make a
website, and then we
had to add our markup to it.
Pretty simple.
So here's an example of what
we built for the website.
In this case, we were
making origami succulents.
This is all normal
markup, but just wanted
to call it a little
bit of the content.
You can see it's more than just
step one, step two, step three.
Schema.org how-to
capabilities have
things like the
tools you'll need,
or the materials
it's going to take,
how long it's going to take, how
much money it's going to take.
So you don't have to
do that, but it just
shows how rich
this content can be
and that the scheme can support.
So after that, all we have
to do is add our markup
to our web page.
And you can see here we
do that with a script tag.
It's of type application
LD plus JSON.
In this case, LD
stands for Link Data.
And you can see it's as simple
as defining this is a how-to.
Here's the description of it.
Here's some of those
estimated costs
and things like
that I talked about.
Another little
chunk of it-- this
is for some actual
how-to content,
so this is a step in the how-to.
It's got a title.
It's got an order.
We can have an
image, a thumbnail,
any of that sort of stuff.
So all this data
then gets processed,
and here's what it looks like.
On the left, you can
see a normal search
if our web page didn't
have this metadata in it.
And it just is a normal title
snippet, pretty standard stuff.
But on the right,
you can see we get
this nice carousel of the steps
involved in making our how-to.
It has even the
materials you'll need.
So for users looking for
content, when they see
this one, it's way more rich.
They're going to see, oh,
this spells it out exactly.
It tells me what I need.
I can see what I'm getting into.
It's going to be great
for all your visitors.
So we had to create a lot
of origami-based content
for this demo, so
that meant we needed
to create a lot of origami.
Here's a lot of--
some of our misfires
or failed attempts.
And luckily, some of
this work overlapped
with Bring Your
Child to Work Day,
so we had a lot of hands-- a
lot of helpers to tell us where
our how-tos were falling short.
So that was an interesting
day in the office.
So here's some resources
to get you started as well.
MARY CHEN: Thanks, Matthew.
So as a web developer
myself, everything you said
sounded really easy.
MATTHEW PEGULA:
Definitely, yeah.
MARY CHEN: How long
did it take you
to get the templates up and
running, and also the markup?
MATTHEW PEGULA: If you already
have the YouTube videos,
if you already
have the web page,
you could probably add
all that in an hour.
MARY CHEN: That's awesome.
So for everyone who creates
content online, whether it's
on YouTube or as websites,
definitely check out our docs
for more information.
And we also had a talk yesterday
from the product managers
on these topics, so give
that a view as well.
All right.
So let's go on to
demo number two.
This is a really tasty one.
It's our S'mores
app, and it's made
with app actions and slices.
These are new ways where you can
take your existing Android app
and integrate it with
a Google Assistant.
That way, users can access
the key functionalities
of your app seamlessly
with their voice
by talking to the
Google Assistant.
All right, Oscar.
Can you tell us about this demo?
OSCAR PROM: Yeah, definitely.
Thanks, Mary.
This was a really
fun demo to cook up
over the last few weeks.
In the sandbox, we have a
few user journeys for people
to try.
First you can order through
the S'mores app using
a standard clickthrough flow.
The screen cap shows a user
selecting a few ingredients,
the toast level, the quantity
before confirming their order.
The next user journey is that
same flow using the new feature
App Actions.
The user speaks their order
via the Assistant, which
opens the S'mores app
with a populated order
ready to confirm.
As you can see, this
is a quicker route
to the desired action than the
standard clickthrough flow.
Finally, you can check your
order status with a slice.
Slices allow you to serve a
custom UI within the Assistant
instead of searching for
that info in the app.
With this feature, a user can
check the last order status
with little overhead.
As you can see, app
actions and slices
allow for a more seamless
experience between an Android
app and the Assistant.
Let's see how the app was made.
The sample was built
using Android Studio
for the app in Firebase
for cloud processing.
We first built out the
basic app functionality,
including an ordering flow,
user handling, a previous orders
list, and so on.
Next, we set up Cloud Firestore
to hold order and user
information and a cloud function
to process any incoming orders.
Then we implemented deep links
to navigate into specific parts
of the app via a URL.
As a side note, if this isn't
a feature you're already
using in your Android
app, it's definitely
something you want
to take advantage of,
as it helps you drive external
traffic into your application.
Finally, we had to
implement the app
actions and slice-specific
pieces of the code.
Let's see what that looks like.
Here's the app actions flow
from a user query into the app.
The query flows into
the Assistant backend
which determines the
built-in intent, if any.
In this case, the user
says, order a dark chocolate
s'more from the S'mores app,
which the Assistant maps
to the order menu item intent.
If there's an app on the device
that can handle that intent,
the apps open with any
relevant parameters,
completing the app actions flow.
Let's dig into the code to see
how easy this is to implement.
Here's an actions.xml file
that exposes, as you'd expect,
an app's actions.
The action tag identifies
any built-in intents
that your app can handle.
There are currently
intents for food ordering,
ridesharing,
fitness, and finance.
As a result of deep
linking, you'll
notice the URL schema and query
parameters in some of the tags.
We've defined many
unique ordering queries.
But in the future, you'll
be able to use parameters
with a query to simplify things.
This means you could use
something like a cracker type
variable in the query definition
and then define those string
options elsewhere.
Next, in our
Android manifest, we
register the actions for our
application using a metadata
tag.
You'll also notice some
deep linking intent filters
within the activity tag with
the URL that matches our action.
Now, when your app
launches, how do you
know if it was a normal run
or triggered by App Actions?
In the main activity, we attempt
to pull out any relevant data
from the incoming intent.
If order information is found,
we populate the pending order
and move directly to
the Order Review screen,
completing the App Actions flow.
So with a few small
code additions,
you can enable App Actions
as another entry point
into your app.
Now let's take a look at slices.
Here's the flow of
a slice from a user
query to an embedded response.
First, the Assistant backend
determines the built-in intent,
the same as we just
saw with App Actions.
A query like check my order
maps to the get order intent.
As you can see, all
of the available items
are available online in
the doc, so check those out
if you want to see what
other intents are available.
After determining if
an app is installed
that can handle that
intent, the Assistant
again requests and displays
the slice from the Android app.
This simple flow helps users
get information more quickly
from your application.
Now let's dive into code.
Again, this intent needs to
appear in our actions.xml file
with a URL from the deep link.
However, the fulfillment
is defined as a slice
rather than opening
the full application.
And to create a slice, we need
to implement a slice provider.
A slice provider builds
and populates a simple UI
to reveal to the user.
The intent's URI can be used
to implement different slices
for different paths.
You might also have a slice for
when the nearest s'more shop is
open or if the s'more of
the day is sold out yet.
You can also define
an action for when
the user taps on a slice.
You can even use a
broadcast receiver
to update a slice's
content dynamically.
Our app has the order
status advancing
every 20 seconds,
which is reflected
when viewing the slice.
In our Android manifest, we
register an intent filter
on the activity and
a slice provider
in the application to expose
those to the operating system.
The intent filter uses that
same s'mores last order URL
to connect it to the action.
Let's look at the
main activity again.
We look for any relevant
data from the incoming intent
to determine if the app
was open from a slice.
In the order status case,
we'll direct the user
to the previous orders list.
And that's really it.
It's that easy to
provide quick information
to the user with slices
within your Android app.
As you can see, implementing
app actions and slices allow
for a cleaner user experience,
which will definitely leave
your users wanting s'more.
Here's some resources
to help you get started.
MARY CHEN: Oscar, I feel
like you made everyone
in the room super hungry now.
OSCAR PROM: Yeah.
Imagine how I felt with a
few weeks of development
and no s'mores.
MARY CHEN: All right.
So you talked about
how easy it is.
Same question as I
gave to Matthew--
how long did it take you
to implement all of this?
OSCAR PROM: Yeah,
so if you already
have an existing Android
app, it would probably
take you less than a workday
to add your first App Action
and slice.
MARY CHEN: That's awesome.
All right.
So as a very quick recap,
the first two demos,
we showed you how easy it
is for content creators, web
developers, webmasters,
and Android app developers
to take your existing
content and integrate it
with Assistant.
And that's a theme that you've
been hearing across I/O talks
this year.
Definitely check out the docs.
We have a lot of
great content for you.
And in the next two
demos, we're going
to show you how to build
engaging and rich actions
from scratch.
So this is going to
require a little more work,
a little more learning.
But you're going to build
really cool demos or really
cool actions, and we're going
to show you some of that.
All right.
So demo number three is a
game called Jungle Dream.
This is made with our new
interactive canvas which
we announced in our keynote.
Basically, this
is a way to build
very visual and
interactive experiences
on smart displays,
essentially a way
to have a web view
on a smart display.
By using only HTML,
CSS, and JavaScript,
you can create a full screen and
customizable images, layouts,
video playbacks, animations,
transitions, you name it.
All right, Matthew.
Can you tell us about this game?
MATTHEW PEGULA: Absolutely.
This is-- I know we're not
supposed to have favorites,
but this is probably
my favorite demo.
So you could see a video
here of what we ended up
building, some pretty
standard chainsaw
stuff on your smart display.
But we're all really big
fans of the Google Home Hub.
So when we heard about
interactive canvas
and the capabilities it
was going to provide,
we were really excited about it.
So what we did was
built a multiplayer,
voice-controlled game
called Jungle Dream.
We took inspiration from
old school adventure games
where you got to navigate
your hero through a bunch
of different situations.
But we got to reimagine it
through the use of voice,
which was really cool
and a fun challenge.
So in ours, you help your
character navigate a jungle
by answering some pretty
nerdy programming trivia.
And this is all powered by the
new interactive Canvas APIs.
So for this demo, there's
two main components.
First there's a
conversational app
that was built with
Dialogflow, and the second
is a web app that could
be built with anything.
And what's really cool
is both of those things
are pretty familiar
territory at this point.
We know how to make these
conversational apps.
We know all the powers
that Dialogflow gives us,
and we can write web apps
in a million different ways.
And what's really exciting here
is the interactive Canvas APIs
bring those two things together.
So we get the power of the
conversational interface
with the flexibility of what
web apps provide us to do
the visual side of things.
So part one on the
Dialogflow side
is we now have the capability
to send an immersive response.
That's an update in
the conversation API.
And basically, now we
can create an intent
that instead of sending
a string or some text
to be spoken to your user, we
can send an immersive response,
which basically
allows us to deliver
a data payload to our web app.
So here's what that looks like.
This one is an example.
It's part of a
cloud function that
sends an immersive response.
If you've done anything
with Dialogflow,
this probably looks
pretty familiar.
The highlighted line here is
what we're really focusing on.
That's where you
may, in the past,
have just sent a string
back, and that string would
have been spoken to your user.
Instead of that,
in this case, we're
sending this immersive response.
And you can see we're
passing it the state data.
Whatever is in that state
is completely up to us.
In this case, we're sending
that it's a player action,
and its value is cut the
vines because we're responding
to a cut the vines intent.
So that's from the Dialogflow
side getting an intent,
being triggered, and
then sending it down
to the web app side.
On the web app side, we now have
access to the Assistant Canvas
JavaScript interface.
What that does is it allows
us to receive those messages
that we're sending
down from Dialogflow
and also to send messages back
to our conversational app.
This is all done just
by registering callbacks
in JavaScript and then handling
these events that come in.
So here's what this looks like.
This is a super
pared-down version
of creating that callback
and setting it up.
But basically, any time we
receive an immersive response,
this on update function
is going to be called,
and we're going to receive
that data that we sent down.
So you can see here
we're checking,
is the player action value in
this data that was sent down?
If so, we're going to handle it.
In our case, we play the
scene of cutting the vines.
So it's that simple.
What's really nice is that the
Assistant Canvas Interfaces
is just brought in through
a script include tag.
It's attached to the window
object, so it's pretty basic.
But that means you
have the flexibility
of probably any framework
that you may want.
So you could either
write stuff from scratch,
or if you're doing
things with react or view
that are already handling
a lot of the state
management for you,
this works really well
because there's no reloading
of URLs or anything like that.
We send these state updates.
You can super quickly
and responsibly
update them and
then respond back.
So in summary, the
interactive Canvas APIs
are a powerful bridge that
allow us to create visually
interactive experiences
using familiar technologies.
So we're really excited to play
with this more and build stuff.
We're really excited to see
what other people build as well.
Here's some resources
to get you started.
I really do want to plug the
Google Interactive Canvas Docs.
It will get you up
and running really
quickly from the conversational
side, set up that bridge
and have the receiving
messages from the web app side.
So you can build out this
really quick skeleton.
And once you do
that, I think you're
going to really be inspired
to try some new stuff.
MARY CHEN: All right, Matthew.
I have a very important
question for you--
tabs or spaces?
MATTHEW PEGULA:
I'm a spaces guy,
but I don't want any trouble
from those tabs people
out there, so I'm
trying to keep it cool.
MARY CHEN: All right.
So if you don't know
what we're talking about,
play this game in our
sandbox, and you'll find out.
I also want to point out the
importance of good conversation
design practices here.
As you're building very rich
and engaging interactions
with your users, understand how
to build really rich dialogue
is important.
We have a lot of great
resources on our website,
so definitely check those
out and learn the foundations
of good conversation design.
All right.
So last but not least,
let's take a look
at demo number four.
This is a really cool herb
garden made with Smart Home.
And our Google Smart
Home APIs allow
you to interact with
a Google Assistant
using your hardware
or IoT devices.
This year we launched
a few new traits,
and we built a really
cool herb garden
to demonstrate
these capabilities.
Oscar, our [? plum ?] master
here, is going to tell us more.
OSCAR PROM: Sure thing, Mary.
We don't have much
time left, but I don't
want to leaf everyone hanging.
Let's watch the demo video.
NARRATOR: We use
the dispense trait
to feed our plants the exact
amount of water and humidity
to keep the soil moist.
All plants need a
little sunshine.
Our plants were
looking a bit haggard,
so we used the rotate
trait to help us trim
those hard-to-reach places.
OK, Google.
Rotate 20 degrees.
OSCAR PROM: So here is
a Smart Home overview.
I bet you couldn't tell that
was my voice in the video there.
Anyways, here's a
high-level overview
of how a Smart Home query
turns into a physical action.
A user query is processed
by the Assistant backend
and then pushed to
your partner server.
That partner server
determines the device
to fulfill that intent
and a relative request
to the particular
smart home device.
There are two custom
components here-- the partner
server in the cloud
and the local device
with hardware and code.
Let's dig into each one
to see how they work.
Let's start with the smart home
traits that we plan to support.
The herb garden highlights
a handful of new traits,
including humidity,
rotation, and dispense.
We've also included zones, which
is a new property of the start
stop trait.
You can think of zones as
subsections of a single device,
such as areas of your lawn
or left and right sides
of a garage.
The highlight here is that
Smart Home traits are constantly
evolving to support new
types of devices and actions
that you can take in your home.
The partner server communicates
with the Assistant ecosystem
to expose devices,
including their traits
and current status.
It also implements OAuth 2.0
to authenticate and verify
your identity.
The good thing is you
don't have to spin up
a new instance for
different devices.
The same partner server can
handle many devices and device
types.
Our implementation was
deployed to App Engine,
but any publicly accessible
server should work.
After deploying the
Smart Home server,
you'll need to
create an associated
action in the Actions console.
When defining your
action, you'll
input the URL where your
Smart Home fulfillment lives.
Now that your partner
server is active,
how does it actually
receive a request?
Smart Home devices talk
to your cloud fulfillment
via WebSockets to handle any
incoming requests from a user.
But it's not enough to
just receive that request.
We need to control hardware
to complete the action
that the user asked for.
The photo on the left shows
the herb gardens project box.
Let's take a look at
the full wiring diagram
to see what's inside.
In the center of the diagram,
we see a Raspberry Pi
attached to a motor
driver hat to control
the plant's rotational motors.
Relays are used to dispense
water from the pumps
and start the off-the-shelf
soil humidifier.
The brightness of
the grow lights
are controlled by a
pulse width modulation
from the Raspberry
Pi's GPO pins.
And finally, what would the
system be without power?
And we use transformers
to pull it from wall power
down to usable voltage levels.
Just a note here--
the Smart Home platform
is hardware agnostic.
So while we use
the Raspberry Pi,
you could use almost
any hardware that
allows for a web connection.
To summarize, a Smart Home query
travels from the user's device
to the Assistant backend
through your Smart Home
fulfillment server and
down to the local device.
Our fulfillment server was
deployed to App Engine,
and we used the Raspberry Pi
to control external hardware.
As an extension of this project,
we could use the new local home
SDK to bypass the fulfillment
server entirely for a more
streamlined local path.
To help you get
started, there are
full build instructions and
code available in the GitHub
read me.
We can't wait to see what
kind of Smart Home devices
you all create.
MARY CHEN: I actually
just want the herb garden
for my own place.
MATTHEW PEGULA: Yeah, it
would be super convenient.
OSCAR PROM: Nice in
the kitchen for sure.
MARY CHEN: Yeah, right?
All right.
So there you have it.
We just went over four really
cool actions in our sandbox
with four very different
development journeys.
As you can see, and
the things that you've
been hearing at this I/O, we
have something for everybody.
So if you're a content creator
or you are a webmaster or a web
developer, check out our new
how-to templates and schema.org
markups so that
your content can be
easily accessible to new
users on the Google Assistant.
And if you're an
Android app developer,
think of all the
key functionalities
of your app you want to
make available on the Google
Assistant, such as a
toothbrush moment or things
where users can re-engage.
And if you're itching
to build something new,
check out our new
interactive Canvas.
We can't wait to see
what kind of fun games
you all come up with.
And then finally, if you
to build cool hardware,
check out our new Smart Home
traits and our Smart Home docs.
We're excited to see what
awesome actions you all build,
so if you publish
anything, definitely let
us know by tagging us on Twitter
or checking out our new Reddit
community.
We're really excited for
everything that is in store,
and we hope that you leave
with a great foundation
to build really awesome actions.
And if you see something cool,
check back with our sandbox.
You have a couple of hours left.
So thanks for joining us, and
have a great rest of the day.
OSCAR PROM: Thanks, everybody.
MARY CHEN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]